maxime vous êtes le fils de hervé sa
mort après avoir été percuté par un
chauffard un chauffard de 89 ans ce que
vous pouvez nous raconter ce qui s'est
passé alors tout bêtement mon père
venait me chercher au collège quand
j'avais 13 ans donc aujourd'hui j'ai 21
ans la quantité dont il ya sept ans
ouais c'est ça et donc à ses joueurs
allure normale vu que j'étais derrière
pas d'excès n'est rien et une personne
âgée de 89 ans nous a coupé la route à
un stop et mon père est mort sur le coup
et moi j'ai eu de graves blessures et
tout ce à quoi j'étais avec lui c'est
une histoire
alors vous avez juste un petit peu été
blessées pouvoir baisser vous avez
encore des séquelles ou pas non j'ai pu
de séquelles mais j'ai quand même pas
mal eu beaucoup de dommages corporels
comme je suis j'ai passé une semaine
dans le coma
fred armoires en souffrance on va animer
partir votre papa lui transport à la
longue c'est sûr qu'avec l'âge il avait
39 ans il a l'amour 40 39 ans lui
conduisait et piloter tout bêtement
voilà et qui même quand on a un très bon
pilote vous voyez en moto et il faut
avoir confiance
ceux qui sont autour et la personne de
89 ans elle dit soit vous lui avez parlé
cette personne après non non non j'ai
peu l'occasion le problème après la
personne n'a rien vu elle a eu juste le
nez cassé la suite à leur bague quoi
aujourd'hui en france il n'existe aucune
limitation d'âge concernant la conduite
ni même des contrôles c'est quelque
chose que vous regrettez je pense que ça
devrait être mis en place
cette part repasser le permis
directement mais directement le tête en
premier temps faire des contrôles à
partir de 60 ans peut-être les personnes
tous les deux ans en faire des contrôles
de réflexe je sais pas de vue les
routiers je sais que ils ont des
contrôles comme ça les conducteurs n'ont
alors selon les chiffres de la sécurité
routière les plus de 65 ans sont
pourtant pas les automobilistes qui sont
les plus responsables des accidents
mortels sur la route mais c'est vrai que
la question elle est de plus en plus
posée parce qu'il ya des gens qui ne
repasse jamais le permis qui ont des 90
95 ans 81 89 ans qui se retrouve au
volant d'une voiture et là c'est
extrêmement grave parce que ça ça a
coûté la vie au papa de maxime et c'est
vrai que moi quand j'ai entendu le
témoignage de maxime je me suis dit il
faut légiférer là dessus